are you leaning more toward television
you're writing no no I've written a lot
of television I love television i watch
more television then I watch films do
you okay but do I really do I love
television I love Doctor Who
okay but no I in in in film I focus on
features I think that's sort of I think
that's where my best work lives is in
features and it's also the best way I
think I can express myself creatively
and so what I look for is ways and means
to you know find funding and financing
for these small little films and I've
been fortunate enough that I've been
able to do them for incredibly small
budgets because I don't really have a
lot of characters in my in my films
because they're just stories they're
just really simple stories about people
and their relationships and it it it it
it it shouldn't cost twenty million
dollars that lets story about you know
for people that are trying to figure our
life and that's kind of stuff I really
dig so when you're writing and you're
trying to keep an idea of keeping costs
down are there times when you'd be like
you know what let me change that to one
room of a an apartment versus someone's
office building because you're thinking
of I don't do that you don't do that
okay I just want to write a story I
think it's I could I think it can be
hurtful to your story to do that because
you just want to tell a good story now
obviously if you've got things at your
disposal you want to write towards those
things if you can and still tell that
story but I think story still has to be
key because if you've got an old
abandoned warehouse that you can shoot
in for nothing that's awesome
but if you just shoot a crap story in an
old abandoned warehouse because you have
it for free you're gonna have a crap
movie so you still have to create a
really good story the the piece that
we're working on now happens mostly in
one house but it's a thriller and it's a
psychological thriller and there's all
kinds of things that are happening in
characters are turning and changing and
you don't know who did what to who and
where and why and it as I was writing it
and reading it back it just became a
compelling story and you know when
you're doing that a lot of times it ends
up reading like a play because you're
not moving around to so many different
locations but that wasn't written to be
in one location it was written and it
happened to be in one location
I would rather write a story first and
then you know compact for budget or
whatever later if that makes sense
do you think that storytelling is as
prevalent and as rich as it once was
maybe no we need taxi justice the
characters is Maximus ODEs that are
better than most movies amazing you know
what I mean this is you know what taxi
probably had a profound effect on how I
write you know enemy because it's just
so good God
and everyone's so flawed in their own
way right I feel like a bull if you
don't need but see that so I'm saying
those stories those people there's
people in a cab garage and you don't
really need to go in a whole lot of
places because the characters were so
strong you know I'm listen there's
stories out there that are fantastic and
there are people out there that are
making wonderful films
both big and small but I think that we
have become a very sort of franchise
motivated industry because you know a
lot of money is being spent on a lot of
films and that money's got to come from
somewhere
and it's got to get me back and you know
you can't you can't make two billion
dollars off of a movie that only cost
ten million dollars you know what I mean
so there's again that's all business
that's all like corporate strategy and
you know industry stuff that some of it
has to do with storytelling some of it
doesn't but I don't know ma'am I think I
think we might be in a place where a
story is gonna become the only
affordable special effect here pretty
soon
you